this coming Monday is Juneteenth
commemorating the emancipation of
African-American slaves some events in
the valley will start this Friday
including one at Pearson Community
Center that's tomorrow and that's where
we find Candace Charles this morning
with a sneak peek at the event tell us
all about it Candace you had some very
talented singers earlier
absolutely and we got one more for you a
nine-year-old that's coming up in a few
seconds here yes this will be Lively
here at the Pearson Community Center
food trucks performances real
conversations about where we've been and
where we're going as a community I have
Robert stroudder here with me from the
Dentistry Community Center it's
partnering with Clark County to bring us
this event tell us a little bit about
what people can expect and they can
expect free food rock climbing all kind
of bouncy rides for the kids and just
entertainment hip-hop and you know it's
a 50th year anniversary and Juneteenth
and so it's we're going to collaborate
both of those together and just enjoy
Juneteenth with our communities
absolutely it's all about the black joy
and one of the big things blackjoy is
the food and I have one of the food
vendors here with me Robert kenbro who's
from the collaborators Club tell us a
little bit about what people can expect
from you so the Raider club we are
located at Centennial Hills Hospital
parking lot so we are bringing the
loader Raider fries and a couple other
things to the menu so we want to be
rocking it out okay I gotta give this a
try really quickly for you guys since
that's what I like to do it looks
delicious
and he was right it was very good really
quickly before we end I might have to
introduce you to this little girl right
here angel James she's gonna be singing
the black national anthem
everyone soon see us a little bit first
who lived every
force and singing
on Friday from six to nine.com